The Joe Rogan experience.
So your pursuit for excellence.
When you're saying,
I've got to get better at Bjj or archery or hunting or whatever,
that isn't coupled with a sort of sense because you're not fucking good enough.
So that's that.
That's the deal to I've cause wonderment.
I love it.
Julie.
Cool
boy in it.
And there's enthusiasm.
I mean,
in everything archery in particular,
it's very,
you know,
there's that book Zen and the art of archery,
which is a,
it's an interesting book.
Uh,
it's,
you know,
I mean I think there's some real great points to it,
but that state of mind that you get when you release an arrow and that arrow
perfectly fines,
it's mark really is and it's you,
it requires so much concentration and focus and technique that you really don't
think about other things.
Beautiful.
And it's cleansing and a lot of ways it's mind cleansing.
I find Jujitsu to be very similar in that way too,
that it's so all encompassing.
It's so,
there's so much on the line,
it's so difficult to do that while it's happening.
You're freeing your mind up.
I mean,
I think of video games in the same way.
All of these things,
so that's bizarre.
All of those things suggest a transmission between the inner and outer worlds in
it.
You're looking at the bull's eye and then,
oh my God,
I've made this thing traverse time and space or Bjj.
I've been shown again and again how to execute is triangle and I've just
actually done it against resistance is amazing to feel that.
It's amazing to feel that the,
that your inner life can express itself in the material world,
whatever.
We'll wherever you are looking to explore that,
to test yourself and when you test yourself and you have to figure your way
through something or change the path because the path that you were on was
unsuccessful.
When you're doing that,
it's really good for the mind and for the,
I hesitate to say the spirit because I think that word spirituality is so beaten
down and abused.
You know what you mean?
It become commodified.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah.
It's like when people call themselves a healer,
like,
all right,
you're really,
yeah,
I've just done some on the way.
We're all healing.
Um,
I mean we're,
we really are all healing each other,
but,
um,
I think there's something to doing difficult tasks that it makes life easier.
I really believe that.
I think it makes life more enjoyable.
I think it makes the bright colors brighter and it makes the,
the dull colors,
even them,
even the,
the bad moments.
If you have real positive experiences with difficult things that you choose to
do on your own,
I think it mitigates most of the hassle of life.
Yes,
I agree with that.
That is,
again,
and I'm not particularly promoting this book because I'd like,
uh,
I'm all right with however things do,
but the point of this mentorship is the idea that someone will exhibit qualities
that you recognize you that haven't fully realized in yourself and that you can
sort of model them and realize them because later you have those qualities.
Oh my Kevin Hart,
we were talking about how horrible I find his positivity.
Me Think so real.
It's unbelievable on a practical level why he's building his standup.
That guy's fucking diligent and the Amandla,
when he talks through his,
when he taught through his work schedule,
you quite,
you fetishize hardworking men.
I think I've heard you talk about Dwayne Johnson and Kevin Hart.
Yeah.
The will that you like.
The idea of men are mad at those people by muscle too.
I'm in the Cryo Chamber.
I don't do that though.
I sleep in,
I call them.
You get to hear what you can do.
A lot of things that they don't do like I,
but I also,
you know,
unlike,
uh,
the Rock,
at least I do stand up,
man.
Kevin does stand up to obviously.